hello rejects it's greg here it's John
we're gonna watch the trade a fourth ah
you a comedian now your son of a [ __ ]
show bet this is gonna be awesome I'm so
excited what is it to do narrow film
[Music]
sequel to King County doubt it ariad my
famous brother Jackie buck not only kids
cute we have one kid she's an adult now
she's getting married I thought she was
a date you say lesbian okay what do I
have to do a children's birthday party
do you want a job you want to be an ass
do I have to choose Haley crystal let's
talk about the support it on a town you
live you Peter how many hours did you
get along me too my dad used to love
your TV show we've watched every episode
always nice to meet a fan well we just
had the one TV knack to this is the
worst state ever just a bunch of hours
hey look are you free tonight what like
a date or it'll be just an appointment
they're not sleeping with you I don't
know what your outfit look you had a
terrible day you just said it let me
take you to a place you might have a
nice time a new york celebrities bring
the hookers to the everything I've done
to you I was there for you when you were
starting out as a young man
I was amazing I here again hi do you
come up with all that on the spot
sometimes yeah are you free on Sunday I
have a wedding to go to oh really you
can see my wingman we have a few laughs
we don't want it to become a thing it's
an honor being here to celebrate Britain
in Frankie's wedding can i address the
800-pound gorilla in the room flow what
have you done to my poor little brother
he was 6 feet tall when you cut now this
is my brother of yours and I know why
you're yelling at him who are you with
you no wonder where dress don't comment
on my channel I want to know what your
expectations are perfect item you what
are you talking about we have three
offers for appearances what did big
shiny don't want you magically the crowd
you're a dancer yeah pump sit on my lap
I'll spin you around on katrinka your
viral again over 3 million views and
eight hours and it is still climbing
what no biz regular play on loan mill
right thank you
and all I need to know is what happens
the day he dies probably gonorrhea I
meant for people wrote this movie yeah
you know it's gonna be good let's start
off with some positives here positive
dinero looks great yeah he looks like
you lost some weight he looks looked
like fresh he doesn't look like you got
like plastic surgery or anything but he
does look like he's healthier look so
you said he has ended party feeling
alive he does he does look a lot better
I mean the cast assembled is exciting
for people who grew up on like
characters who were based out of New
York you know you got Harvey kite
alligator you know you got Billy Crystal
making an appearance in there damn you
know from New York he's got that East
Coast personality yeah I mean he's got
the kind of an exit don't ya there's a
taxi driver he fits right in there and I
feel like eating Falco fits in there too
or taxi was the show taxi driver was De
Niro the trailer itself is just cut
together a little weird it looks like a
heartwarming kind of good nurturing time
it doesn't like a human drama d yeah
yeah it doesn't look like it's gonna go
to dark it doesn't look it's gonna get
too serious looks like there's always
gonna be a personality and life about it
looks like an enjoyable time but at the
same time doesn't look like it's gonna
get too funny on ya either yeah I like
it cuz it seems to have a tone down
realistic kind of touch to it it doesn't
look like it the stakes are higher or
anything like that it doesn't it like
there's an intense pool but it does look
like a nice sincere drama yeah this
person's life and then him just getting
older trying to make things work falling
in love you know who had a password he
was a legendary comedian now he's older
like I like exploring those themes oh I
mean I'm wondering if it might feel a
little I don't know if the words empty
but you know having some type of void of
drama yeah yeah it's the kind of story
that I do enjoy but you know we see this
kind of thing every once in a while is
that like older guy looking for love and
meaning to live way it's simple and it's
pleasant and I think this is cool for
Leslie Mann to be doing this you know
film that's not a Judd Apatow phone
number her to be doing this role
engineer I mean who would what younger
actress wouldn't want to play De Niro's
love interest yeah like anyone would
take that on
well the main draw of this for me is the
cast you know because the thing about
like even though this is a weird trailer
i feel like the cast all really enticed
me like the charm of the people involved
there seems to be personality here like
in all the characters and it doesn't
seem force like that's what i was
enjoying about the trailer was
regardless it doesn't look like deep
dramatic you know Harvey Keitel and
deniro like they've done the fast with
like Scorsese films it still is like
they look like they're having a good
time they don't look like they're just
cashing in a check it just feels like
human beings talk seems like they're
actually doing a movie again instead of
being like stunt cast for stuff
especially Robert De Niro I'm curious
about this cuz it looks like he's just
in an actual movie again and not a movie
that's like yeah it's funny cuz ya know
he's not supposed to be a dirty old
grandpa or something yeah there seems to
be a genuine vibe about it which I which
I really was enjoying yeah me at times
the trailer did seem a little off in
terms of like okay we're trying to hook
up us a lot of plot here sometimes I'm
like the trailer works best when you're
just showing relationship interactions
me some good seats cuz this was like
here's what act one looks like here's
what I to looks like here's just a bunch
of random moments that are gonna take
place but the best moments of the
trailer were all the human interactions
yeah Deon just seemed like oh my god
Harvey Keitel again or it's Billy
Crystal nerd just seeing the
interactions everyone seems to be
playing off each other naturally and I
don't mind that in a movie granted
they're not my favorite kind of films
but I like in a movie when it's just
like yeah I just human beings talking
the trailer to me almost feels like they
wanted to make us think that this was a
really plotting movie even though I
think this is just gonna be sort of like
a you know a human from whole time yeah
just want to slice it like slice of life
with a little bit of motivation for
something to add and De Niro is very
much in love with New York City and this
film has has that kind of homage old
school love vibe to New York and what's
great about saying like old school like
that kind of jazz Flair stand-up comedy
clubs in New York is it's still like
that been like yeah york city is still
that way well there's like a real New
York like action guys Harvey Keitel's so
yeah and that's why I'm not upset seeing
them in something that's not a gangster
movie yeah like this looks kind of like
a natural way for them to reunite just
you know acting together yeah cuz that's
something that can become sort of cheesy
and like you know when Nero got back
together Al Pacino
like I was four right just kill which
seems like I stunt you know on both
sides the Taylor Hackford director
devil's advocate which had an Al Pachino
so now when they do the sequel ah we're
competing comedian say it seems advocate
all right really Jax extra tuned into
the channel appreciate you recommending
that our away if you're new to this
channel subscribe to did it get accepted
you fellow reject John resist a Giri on
Twitter and Instagram and he does the
social media management facebook.com
slash bloom house and the real rejects
as well do those things and shout out to
o Pacino I want to be in the comedian
part toe gonna tell jokes haha that's
great joke Greg pony once how did
Captain Hook he wiped his ass with the
wrong hand haha